do you think he'd be a good Prime
Minister I think he would he's very
clear Michael is very clear about what
he wants there's no escaping with him so
the country would perfectly understand
what he wanted and he was set out a very
clear policy agenda he he sometimes
makes the wrong decisions but we're all
human beings
I made wrong I made bad decisions from
time to time but he's prepared to listen
and what I'm keen to can talk about the
issue that we've got you here for we
just sort of fell on funding in schools
and you hear very different things
coming from teachers and coming from
politicians so who is right dis calls
have enough money no they don't no they
don't
I was lucky enough to be a head teacher
in East London when there was money and
I could raise standards because I did
have money but since I left off said
I've been in the number of schools up
and down the country particularly the
north of England and they are struggling
for funding there's no question about
that
and it's sad to see and it's all very
worrying that the that the great
progress that we've made in schools and
in educational standards over the last
20 30 years standards of improved
remarkably it's worrying that there
could be a slowdown so you think that's
under threat then it is under threat and
and that standards could fall and fall
particularly in those parts of the
country I was worried about when I was
chief inspector areas of great
disadvantage who which need money more
than those areas where there is less
disadvantage and it's particularly
worrying in schools with high numbers of
special-needs children as you just shown
do you think the government's been
misleading when it says that there's
record levels of funding in our schools
yes but as that a head teacher rightly
pointed out there are many more children
in our schools now than there were a few
years ago national insurance
contributions that and pension
contributions that schools have to pay
have also gone up and that the big
challenge for our system at the moment
is that we have not got enough teachers
and good leaders in our schools top them
to head
as I do all the time and they will say
funding is an issue it's particularly an
issue when they can't attract good
enough people into our schools to raise
standards so unless we can do that and
pay teachers enough money to come into
the profession and stay in the
profession and retention is probably
even more important than the recruitment
than work they will see a decline in
standards do you think the standards in
our schools are mediocre well they're
better now as I said than they were when
I started teaching back in the dark ages
but they're better now but the big
challenge for our country is is huge
regional performance I mean I constantly
banged on about standards in the north
of England and in some parts of the
Midlands secretary performance in
particular is not good enough in in the
north well not when I say when in my
last year as chief inspector not one
youngster on free school meals got into
Oxford's from the whole of the North
East of England Yorkshire and Humber
side and in that same region three times
and less children go to university than
they do in the South now that's not good
enough and what's what's the problem I
mean you've spoken before haven't you
you haven't minced your words when it
comes to teachers and when it comes to
parents as well do you think who has to
shoulder the responsibility well
leadership is critical you can get good
teachers in the school unless they are
led well and you've got a strong head
teacher in the school then it won't go
well and is it really sad that we're not
doing enough to nurture our future
leaders
in this country the national college of
school leadership was closed down some
years ago nothing has has really
replaced it and in the in the worst
schools that we see in the country we
see poor leadership but parents have got
a part to play why is it that London
does very well in all the metrics why
because none of our immigrant families
in our capital city have parents who
value education support education and
our ambitious for their children why do
we see some young young youngsters in
from white British working-class
families doing badly often it's because
their parents don't support them and
they were in the way that our immigrant
family
dude is there anything we can do about
this well school great schools can
connect as local are in loco parentis
and act as surrogate parents and do
their best but families are the great
educators you and I are what we are
because the families we came from and
the love and the care and the support
they gave us actually if parents don't
care and don't support then then schools
struggle and you know I've been quite
I've said some tough things about
parenting and we should be tough on
parents who don't support their schools
and and in some instances are are
abusive to teachers and have teachers do
you think it's talking about ambitious
parents do you think is immoral when
wealthier parents move into the
catchment area of a good school well
parents do that and they buy houses or
rent houses and and all the rest of it
parents want the best for their children
you can't stop that happening you know
you can't legislate against it it what
we need to do as a country ensure that
every school is a good school every
school is an outstanding school so that
the choice becomes that much greater for
parents and then just finally what we've
got you I mean the whole point of this
series is to try and shine a light on
issues that are perhaps falling down the
political agenda because it breaks them
because of the leadership contest are
you worried that's happening to
education yes and what we need is an
education secretary I'm sure we have one
in Damon who's going to fight the corner
I mean the Autumn Statement will be
critical the Chancellor's autumn budget
will be absolutely critical and every
every head teach in the country were
looking very close to hear that and I'm
sure Damian Hynes will be fighting the
education corner very vociferous to
ensure that some of the issues we've
just been talking about are addressed by
the government because as I said the
huge progress that we've made and
there's a lot more to do in the country
regional performance etc that huge Pro
graph is progress is in danger of
falling back unless the funding funding
goes into school